[Music]
all right today's question comes from
ozzy in california i'm currently taking
financial peace university with my
girlfriend i've completed baby steps one
through four and should have my current
house paid for and at one and a half
years
i've also been saving for a second house
so my mom can live in my current house
when my girlfriend and i get married my
girlfriend has a hundred thousand
dollars in student loan debt and
recently booked a trip to visit friends
on the east coast she said that she
wants when she gets married and has kids
she won't be able to do a trip like this
so she wants to go now
my first reaction was that she should
not go on this trip because of her
student debt and when i told her this
she told me you know what you should
enjoy your money so who's right in this
situation
what do you think dave
um if you marry this girl it's gonna be
a long life i was gonna say man y'all
are not aligned
this is um
the old joke is if you marry a woman
that likes to spend money you better
enjoy making it
but that's a negative joke i mean the
same will be true opposite if you marry
a duber who doesn't earn any money you
know i mean there's
it's um
yeah you got you got a problem that's
bigger it's this yolo problem this i'll
never be able to once i get married and
have kids my life's over i can't hang
out with my friends and so uh then
there'll be another thing there'll be
another thing no there'll be another
always yes so here's the rule okay
adults devise a plan and follow it
children do what feels good
you're dating a child sir
was that what i'm i think i must be in a
mood no that sounds a little harsh i
don't think it's harsh at all i think
it's
i was kinder than i was it was more
eloquent than i was gonna say
um you've got well i mean i just called
his girlfriend a baby doll i mean she's
just a child but i mean it's not it's
not that's kind of harsh but yeah well
she was grown up enough to take out a
hundred thousand dollars in student
loans yeah but that just means she was
18. that's right she has a chronological
thing
emotional maturity that's true
yeah the reality is you have
lined up your life in a way that you're
almost done paying for your house
um you're working on a second house
you're working on all your financial
house in order you're thinking about
your mom you're filling the blank and
you've got somebody who's saying hey you
know what we gotta live for right now
because the life gets awful down the
road so let's just live for the right
now yeah and those are competing
philosophical ways of doing life
see yolo contends
that tomorrow doesn't matter
because it's not guaranteed right
yolo contends
that
yolo is rationalization
and justification
for
doing what the four-year-old child
inside of me wants to do right
that's what yolo is right
you know yolo says that if you plan for
something and save for it and pay for it
that you are no fun
because you could have just had it now
you're no fun right you're no fun
and you don't have as much fun right
well let me tell you
about my life
you know what i do now
anything i want exactly yes if i want to
get on a plane and go to somewhere i can
just do it i mean that that's fun yes
but it didn't get there by yolo right
and so if you live like no one else
later you can live and give like no one
else but so you can't presuppose and i'm
sorry for you little children that live
in your mommy's basement and don't like
dave ramsey being a boomer and all this
crap
uh but uh but the the deal is if you
want to have
a there's a adult fun and i'm not
talking about
uh
something nasty i'm talking about but a
grown grown-up fun for grown-ups
is a richer deeper kind of fun right you
know i got seven grandkids i can
load them all on a plane and take them
somewhere
anytime i want
and that's a different thing than
i get to go out and eat whenever i want
to go out and eat because you only live
once and you don't have to check the
account right you don't have to
you know
i don't have to go look and see if i can
afford it that's what i'm saying there's
a piece to
to joy and to fun that the yolo misses
yeah yolo is about the heart rate spike
it's not about the entire experience
which is
i can sleep tonight i'm not worried
about it
it's a
it's a roller coaster of excitement yeah
versus you're looking for a hit right
versus deep joy yeah but it's like a it
is like a drug hit you know it's a
dopamine hit and then
you're always going to come down from
that hit so you got to do it again you
got to do it again you got to do it
again yeah so there is inside of us a
little kid that throws a fit on the
cereal aisle and wants the frosted nut
roasted nut cheerios whether you can
afford them or not and mom says no
you're four
don't throw a fit in the grocery store
because i'll bust your little butt
right but that little kid lives inside
of every one of us i want it i want it
now and then they we say stupid stuff
like i deserve it
i've worked hard so this let me help you
with this you don't deserve nothing nope
nothing
you don't deserve nothing unless you go
get it
save up the money and pay for it and
then you can say i deserve it but you
don't deserve it because you breathe air
you entitled a little twit
oh my god
no that's just not true right it's just
not i mean
i can say that to myself because that
little kid lives inside oh he's in me
too yeah he's inside of every one of us
his name is immaturity right
and the more we don't feed that little
kid
the sooner he's not there anymore so
this happened in my life then you just
grow up in your grouchy and direct with
a guy who's a girlfriend in california
but yeah we we ordered some uh we've had
the same crummy front porch furniture
forever it wasn't your front porch
furniture it's just it's just might be a
hillbilly super uncomfortable right you
might be a hillbilly if and finally i
got frustrated a few weeks ago a few
months ago oh you deserve some furniture
well i thought i'm i make good money why
am i living like this and then my wife
said
because we haven't saved up and we can't
afford that yet
and i was like oh yeah oh yeah and so
then we made it a priority and then we
got it
and we got it this week we i think we
have an archer dave
it's my it's it's mine yeah we paid for
it we saved for it and it's super
comfortable yeah and now i can sleep on
it without worrying about the payments
it doesn't doesn't it sits different i
promise you some of you people financed
your bed just think about that
just think about that right uh
how are you sleeping in a financed bed
oh john will never be out of business